14 days that's how long Xi Jinping was
missing before he suddenly became
China's leader back in 2012. so he got
99.86 of the vote during this time he
canceled meetings with foreign leaders
and Chinese media refused to comment on
the situation people naturally started
to speculate perhaps he had been
replaced or thrown in prison or even
assassinated government sensors blocked
search results for his name anywhere on
the internet and then out of nowhere he
resurfaced the Chinese Communist party
just acted like nothing had happened and
they appointed him General Secretary
exactly where he was during that
two-week stretch is still unknown to
this day but understanding his journey
to become the most powerful man in the
world is key to understanding the future
of the global World Order Xi Jinping is
an enigma in many ways his entire life
is shrouded in mystery but thanks to
some Intrepid reporting by Anonymous
sources we're starting to learn more now
we know that he grew up in an extremely
time for China political power was
shifting quickly and It ultimately tore
his family apart but somehow C remained
dedicated to the Chinese Communist party
to understand why we have to go back to
the 1950s
Mao Zedong was the founder of the
People's Republic of China and led the
entire country as the chairman of the
Chinese Communist Party C's father
worked for Chairman Mao directly as
secretary for industrial Affairs this
was a very important role and it allowed
their family to live in a part of town
reserved for party officials the
neighborhood was gated and had security
patrolling the entrance the government
paid for nannies and housekeepers and
the accommodations were luxurious Xi
Jinping was born in that private Beijing
neighborhood in 1953 although he wasn't
directly in line for a political
position he was practically royalty his
father was critical to the founding of
Chairman Mao's Empire and was routinely
featured in party propaganda Mao had
successfully unified China and ended the
so-called Century of humiliation that
came before it
Decades of rebellion civil conflicts
Imperial invasions and political
upheaval had come to an end and C's
father was right at the heart of the New
Order even though he was a hero in the
political realm C's father was a strict
disciplinarian at home the children of
Mao's revolutionary compatriots were
called the red second generation or
princelings since they were set to
inherit this new Unified Government but
parents were worried that these
princelings would become entitled so
they enforced strict rules at home not
much is known about C's mother she's
still alive today at over 90 years old
and C keeps a picture of her on his desk
but reports show that she's kept a low
profile on purpose see didn't spend much
time with his parents growing up because
he went to an exclusive boarding school
but his time living a fancy life as part
of the political Elite wouldn't last
long
[Applause]
Mao Zedong was working to abolish
private ownership of farmland and build
up Chinese industrial capacity but it
wasn't going well this so-called Great
Leap Forward led to mass starvation and
even seized fancy boarding school
couldn't get enough food to feed the
students dictators like Chairman Mao put
loyalty above all else it didn't matter
if people were dying left and right as
long as they could still rule with an
iron fist anyone who questioned Mao's
plan was swiftly dealt with and C's
father was no exception his father had
written a novel about the Chinese Civil
War and in the process been critical of
Mao's leadership so in 1962 he was
removed from government and put on house
arrest Mao had to be sure that C's
father would never question his
authority again so he sent him to a
labor camp to live out his days in
poverty this was just the start of a
broader consolidation of political power
though the late 1960s brought the
cultural revolution and with it broad
attacks on anyone who questioned China's
new socialist Doctrine teachers were
shamed for allowing free thought people
were beaten tortured and even killed
even though Xi Jinping was still just a
boy he was brutally punished for his
father's sins Mao loyalists brought C to
a courtyard in Beijing to shame him the
crowd chanted slogans about how
dishonorable he had been and even forced
his mother to participate in the public
denunciation these Mao loyalists were
called red guards and they would stop at
nothing to enforce compliance with the
new political regime they broke into
Sea's boarding school and dragged the
teachers into the street they even built
makeshift prisons to lock people up it
was a horrible time for the country and
C's family was suffering his older
half-sister took her own life because of
the stress it caused her and in later
accounts C has said that he thought he
might die too
at age 14 C was locked in a detention
center and left to starve one night he
managed to run away and make it home to
his mom to ask for some food but the
risk of getting caught was simply too
high so his own mother had to turn him
into the authorities
this kind of chaos was unsustainable
even under Chairman Mao's authoritarian
rule so something had to be done the
solution was to send young people out of
the cities and into the farmlands to
learn the virtues of hard labor from
ordinary peasants C was only 15 when he
was sent to a tiny village to start
working but surprisingly he remembers
this time fondly for C it was an
opportunity for personal growth and a
chance to become a stronger man survival
in Beijing had become increasingly
difficult so C was excited for a new
beginning even if it meant leaving his
family behind but his time on the farm
was far from his expectations he was
forced to live in a cave with very
little to eat and the locals didn't even
like him he started smoking cigarettes
just so that he could take more breaks
from the hard work after only a few
months he couldn't take it anymore so he
escaped and headed back to Beijing his
plan was half-baked though and he was
arrested almost immediately and forced
to build sewers throughout the city one
year later he decided to give the
country side another shot so he headed
back to the farm and eventually was able
to have an impact on the village he put
his education to use and helped build
Wells dams and New Roads at age 22 he
was finally ready to depart for good
this time from New York this is ABC News
good evening matsudong the most powerful
influence on China since Confucius has
died at the age of 82. this was a really
critical turning point for China
Chairman Mao died in 1976 bringing the
cultural revolution to an end finally
the mark on C's family could be lifted
and everyone could reunite the young
princelings were back in the political
Elite so most of them started
celebrating they drank and partied but
not Xi Jinping you would think that
after watching Mao's cultural revolution
destroy his entire childhood C would
reject the Communist party but he did
the exact opposite C never wanted to be
in that position again so he started
working to gain political power he had
seen firsthand to help business of
political Outsiders and so he had to
double down on the Communist Party the
CCP still had complete control over
China but it was the leader of the party
who had the real power Xi Jinping would
need to climb the ranks and reach the
top to fulfill his mission in 1975 he
managed to earn admission to a
university to go study chemical
engineering the Chinese academic system
had been gutted during the cultural
revolution and nearly every class had
been restructured to teach the writings
of Mao Zedong getting into a good
University was no longer about getting
good grades and passing the entrance
exams the name of the game was getting a
strong recommendation from a local party
leader even though the classes were more
focused on Marxist theory than solving
true engineering problems the degree was
enough to let C qualify for political
positions so he called up his father who
is no longer a political Exile and asked
for some help his father was able to get
him a job with a military official as a
secretary it wasn't glamorous work
mostly just managing schedules taking
notes in meetings and helping with
speeches but it allowed him to form
relationships with senior Army officials
because of the chaos of the cultural
revolution C's boss didn't want him to
write anything down that could be used
against him in the future so C would
have to take notes then run to the
bathroom to memorize everything before
burning the paper he had just written on
C was learning about the complicated
power dynamics in China the Army
officials he was working with were the
people's Liberation Army or pla these
soldiers don't serve China broadly
instead they report directly to the
Chinese Communist Party their job is
first and foremost to keep the
Communists in charge and prevent any
attempt at a coup if C wanted to one day
run the Chinese Communist Party he would
have to Cozy up to the pla in hindsight
working in this lowly position was
incredibly valuable because it gave him
military credentials but just as he was
starting to make progress he decided to
completely change trajectories he again
returned to the poor rural Chinese
country side to integrate with the
average worker this time as Deputy party
secretary it was a tough job far away
from the Comforts of the city life but
it was a critical function for the
Communist Party the Communist Regime
needed the support of average peasants
so sending officials out to promote the
party line was a win-win spread the
message of Communism while identifying
future Party leaders Xi Jinping had
positioned himself perfectly to join the
ranks of the next generation of
Communist Party leadership this was a
critical moment as the Communist party
was going through a major strategic
shift the famines caused by the Great
Leap Forward and the violence caused by
the cultural revolution had eroded
confidence in the Communist party and
they needed a new Direction so they
decided to dial things back a bit
instead of extreme socialism with
complete Collective control of all
industry the free market would need to
start playing a role it would be
socialism with Chinese characteristics
and It ultimately led to massive
economic growth good morning well
history is about to be made on the south
lawn of the White House for President
Carter will officially greet Chinese
Vice Premier Deng Xiaoping the first
Chinese Communist official to make a
state visit to the United States there
was a new leader now his name was Deng
xiaopeng and he was so dedicated to
reforming China that he even visited
America personally to build a
relationship between the two countries
International Trade would come to define
the Chinese growth story over the next
decades but this transformation wouldn't
happen overnight Xi Jinping was looking
for a new job and a unique opportunity
popped up in fujian Province this
mountainous region on China's southern
coast had been a major international
trading Hub until Mao Zedong closed off
China to the world fujan had become one
of China's poorest provinces but that
was an opportunity for C he spent 17
years there working his way up in the
local government and keeping a low
profile even though C was making solid
progress sticking his neck out too much
could be risky so he rarely spoke
publicly part of the reason he was so
careful about flying under the radar was
the rampant corruption that plagued
China at the time every major city had
their fair share of Wheeler Dealer types
that were constantly making backroom
deals to keep imports and exports
flowing one of the most prominent bosses
was a man named Lai Chung sing and he
was operating right in XI jinping's
backyard for years lye had been running
a massive smuggling business in fujan
and in the process avoided paying
billions of dollars in taxes lye had
focused on one of the ports in fujian
Province right across from Taiwan his
smuggling Empire had illegally imported
billions of dollars worth of cigarettes
cars and oil all directly under the
noses of local officials much like Xi
Jinping Lai Chung sing had spent years
as a ditch digger living an impoverished
lifestyle but once China started opening
up to foreign trade he saw an
opportunity lye was barely literate but
he was a master of building connections
and manipulating people he realized
early on the biggest winners during the
next economic boom wouldn't necessarily
be the smartest or most educated people
but instead the people who were able to
control government officials so lye
started growing his Network and
reinvesting all of his profits into
bribes whenever times were tough he was
quick to help the police army or other
government workers with whatever they
needed to get done the strategy worked
and after a few years lye controlled the
entire Port system he was so connected
that he could drive right into the
Chinese Capital without getting stopped
by the guards he even built a new
airport to speed up trade and was
responsible for one-sixth of all Chinese
oil imports lye was becoming a local
hero because even though he was breaking
the law he had so many people on his
payroll that everyone still loved him he
was basically the Pablo Escobar of China
in the 1990s and just like Escobar he
bought a local soccer team to further
cement his name in history for his most
important assets he built a pleasure
Palace where absolutely everything was
free lavish dinners endless gambling
even prostitution anything was possible
at ly's headquarters and it kept
everyone looking the other way on his
Corrupt Practices eventually lie's
fraudulent Empire became too big to
ignore so the Chinese government cracked
down they sent investigators to arrest
him but he was tipped off by his local
contacts and escaped the country he
sailed to Hong Kong on a boat and then
flew to Canada the corruption Scandal
resulted in over 150 of his associates
getting arrested and some of them wound
up getting the death penalty lye claimed
that he had done nothing wrong and the
Chinese government was going after him
purely for political reasons he
requested political asylum in Canada but
was eventually sent back to China after
spending 12 years fighting his case he
was arrested as soon as he landed and
quickly sentenced to life in prison even
though the Chinese government made an
example of lie he clearly wasn't the
only one doing this type of thing at
that time corruption was rampant and
nearly every major government official
was assumed to be involved in either
bribery tax evasion or some other abuse
of power the question is what XI
jinping's role was in all of this after
all he was a senior party official in
fujan at the time and it's hard to
imagine that he wasn't aware of what was
happening well even if C turned a blind
eye to corruption in fujan it didn't
hurt his political career because he was
born a princeling he already had plenty
of connections and likely didn't need to
get involved directly with lye's Empire
that put him in the perfect position to
clean up the Scandal so Beijing
officials tapped him to put an end to
corruption once and for all the official
history of Xi Jinping doesn't mention
any ties to corrupt business practices
China clearly doesn't want to tarnish
their Leader's image but in 2012
Bloomberg News reported that C's family
owned hundreds of millions of dollars in
real estate and other business assets
and a Chinese billionaire told the New
York Times that he had helped the sea
fam dump some assets but this
billionaire quickly disappeared from a
Hong Kong hotel and then was sentenced
to 13 years in prison for bribery and
Corruption
sees wealth remained shrouded in mystery
to this day after all he might really
believe in communism to such an extent
that he never crosses the line but still
many questions remain one of C's
predecessors Deng Xiaoping had a famous
saying hide your strength and bide your
time it appears that Xi Jinping had
taken this to heart he had always prized
power over wealth and had seemingly
unending patience he never overestimated
his power and he never stuck his neck
out desperately grasping for more it
served him well because in 2002 hujin
Tao became General Secretary and opened
up a wave of New Opportunities Xi
Jinping had spent 17 years in fujan but
now it was time to travel North to
jojiang it didn't matter that
businessmen were getting rich through
corrupt business practices C had his eye
on real power political power and
positioning himself as the
anti-corruption leader who the Communist
Party could count on was the perfect
move in 2006 hujin Tao was consolidating
power and that meant getting rid of the
current leader in Shanghai whenever
Chinese leaders remove their Challengers
they almost always claim that they're
fighting corruption that's the ruling
party the greatest threat we face is
corruption this strategy works great
since nearly everyone is involved in
corruption at some level Xi Jinping was
The Logical choice to take over in
Shanghai since he had publicly steered
clear of corruption and helped clean up
the Lai Chung Singh scandal in fujan
most importantly though C was also a
political independent his loyalty and
patience was finally being rewarded
every five years the Chinese government
held a party Congress this event would
decide who ran the country as well as
who was next in line the 17th party
Congress was a particularly important
turning point for caesarin Peng as the
party's leader hujin Tao walked on stage
he was followed by members of his pullet
Bureau these were the men who were next
in line for the top job and Xi Jinping
was ahead of his main rival he was
basically on track to serve as vice
president and eventually lead all of
China only one question remained could C
continue to keep a low profile and stay
away from scandals China had struggled
under hujin Tau and was eager to find a
stronger leader to take the party
forward even though Xi Jinping had
styled himself as a reserved and
diligent servant to the party he was
quietly planning to adopt a much more
aggressive stance
[Music]
aware of Xi Jinping in the early 2000s
but in 2008 China would host the
Olympics in Beijing and see would
preside over the games it was a time of
great optimism the Chinese Olympics had
been hailed as a turning point in
China's development The Hope was that
the country would become more open more
democratic and more free but even though
China had welcomed visitors to the
massive stadium in Beijing they also had
ramped up military operations and
security measures to suppress local
protests Xi Jinping had a major problem
on his hands it was a problem faced by
all authoritarian governments who stay
in power for decades the population must
be kept in check at all times in a
democracy disgruntled citizens have an
outlet for their frustrations if enough
people are unhappy with the current
leadership they can vote in a new
government the Chinese Communist Party
didn't want to give up control under any
circumstances so managing dissent was
critical I know this is the first Arab
revolution of the 21st century Mubarak
deposed Egypt's 18-day Revolution here's
a theater of the Absurd a murderous
clown in 2011 Joe Biden flew to China to
meet with Xi Jinping they were both
serving as vice presidents at the time
and were grappling with the global
political issues of the day the Arab
Spring had caused massive upheaval in
countries like Tunisia Libya Egypt and
Yemen anti-authoritarian protests had
spiraled into violent confrontations and
calls for new governments C was clearly
worried that something similar could
happen in China after all the same
government corruption that had forced
Middle Eastern citizens onto the streets
was rampant in China government
officials had taken bribes and cut
corners while construction companies
were building schools these shoddy
structures had collapsed during a major
earthquake and killed tens of thousands
a Chinese infant formula company had
paid off regulators and covered up a
tainted batch which caused thousands of
children to develop learning
disabilities and across the country
corrupt government officials had stolen
land from local farmers and sold it off
to the highest all while pocketing the
profits this was just how things got
done in China at the time even the
smallest interactions with the
government like getting an ID card would
require a bribe sometimes it was just a
few packs of cigarettes but often party
officials would take everything they
could this had been boiling over into a
major protest movement it was extremely
risky for citizens to take to the
streets but they had no options left
there was just no way for an honest
person to make it in China you either
had to start a business and bribe the
government to get ahead or work for the
party and extort locals Xi Jinping knew
that China was uniquely vulnerable he
couldn't let the revolutionary ideas of
the Arab Spring spread to the Chinese
populace fortunately for C in addition
to being the vice president he was also
serving as the first Secretary of the
Secretariat it's a bit of an opaque
title but it gave him much more power
and a unique insight into the day-to-day
operations of the party's bureaucracy
this role allowed him to learn the inner
workings of the party and understand how
to actually get things done efficiently
but while C was grinding through the
bureaucracy and keeping his head down
another man had his sights on becoming
China's top dog his name was bosu Lai
and he had a very similar upbringing to
Xi Jinping they're both roughly the same
age and they both come from prominent
political families but bosu Lai wasn't
interested in keeping a low profile he
wanted power and everyone knew it bosu
Lai was more like a western politician
than others who had come before him he
loved the spotlight and he had a great
sense of humor he also pushed lots of
populist policies and tried to appeal to
the largest audience possible like C
Beau saw that getting tough on
corruption was the quickest path to
power but he was too gung-ho about it
his fellow party members could see
through his rhetoric and knew that he
was arrogant and overly ambitious back
in 2007 Beau sulai was serving the party
in Chongqing the city was absolutely
massive but with this scale came tons of
problems pollution was getting worse
every day and or organized crime was
running the City beau's Mission was
simple clean up the city and use that as
a platform to gain political power so he
teamed up with a grizzled police chief
named Wang Lee Jun together they purged
criminal organizations from the city and
for a time where hailed as saviors but
that wouldn't last Beau was engaging in
his own corruption and feared that he
would be caught so he fled to the
American Consulate over time the truth
surfaced not only had Beau been corrupt
but his wife had killed an American
businessman by poisoning him Beau was
stripped of his government title and his
wife was found guilty of murder all of a
sudden one of China's most promising
leaders had been unmasked as a corrupt
fraud it was a massive setback for a
government that had been trying to prove
that scandals were limited to lower
ranking officials even the top party
leadership was capable of horrific
actions which would undermine trust in
the system so there were two possible
paths forward give more power to the
people or completely centralized control
unsurprisingly the party decided that
they needed even stronger leader someone
who could root out corruption once and
for all it's unclear what role Xi
Jinping played in all of this but the
end result was certainly to his benefit
since bosu Lai was his primary
Challenger for control this is one of
the leading theories for what happened
during the 14 days Xi Jinping was
missing in 2012. no one knows for sure
but shortly after C's disappearance bosu
Lai was removed from power and charged
with corruption by November the party
had Consolidated around sea and sworn
him in as general secretary osulai would
wind up getting sentenced to life in
prison C had successfully Consolidated
power within the Chinese Communist party
but this was really just the start after
all no one wants to be at the helm of a
Dying party and quickly get overthrown
by a populist Revolution control over
the Chinese population would be a new
challenge entirely and Xi Jinping would
look to history to inform his strategy
so now we gotta talk about Tiananmen
Square a brutal Massacre of Chinese
students and other protesters by the the
Chinese Army the death count goes on
tonight it may go as a high as a
thousand or more and the fighting is not
yet over in the late 1980s China was
changing calls for democracy were
getting louder and louder each day and
the party could no longer ignore them
there was a real risk that the Chinese
Communist Party could fall if something
wasn't done protesters had gathered in
Tiananmen Square to demand democracy in
an end to the Relentless political
corruption citizens were closer than
ever to grasping Freedom so the Chinese
leadership had to take drastic measures
it wasn't just average citizens who were
calling for change several party
officials were also sympathetic to the
protesters so Deng Xiaoping sent the
Army to Tiananmen Square and locked up
the most prominent official who had been
supporting the protest we still don't
know the official death toll but it's
likely in the thousands photos and
videos from that incident are heavily
censored to this day the protests
weren't confined to Beijing though they
had already spread across the country
and even though Xi Jinping was thousands
of miles away in southern China at the
time the official party history states
that he remained loyal to the party and
blocked local students from protesting
having lived through the chaotic
cultural revolution C believed that
democracy would lead to more violence
not less and dedicated himself to
consolidating authoritarian control but
although the Chinese Communist Party had
managed to stay afloat in 1989 the
Soviet Union wasn't so lucky Mikhail
Gorbachev was celebrated in the West for
bringing an end to the Cold War but Xi
Jinping saw the fall of the Soviet Union
as a massive failure after all the
original Chinese Communist Revolution
was heavily inspired by the Russian
Revolution so watching a similar system
collapse was terrifying the Chinese
Communist party is haunted by the fall
of the Soviet Union to this day and has
become completely obsessed with avoiding
a similar fate so why did the Soviet
Union fall and what exactly would XI
jinping's survival plan look like well
in C's mind China would need to do two
main things differently first they would
need to double down on indoctrination
everyone had to understand the history
of the Communist party or at least a
positive version of the history that
would lead everyone to fall in line
there could be no room for ideological
exploration second the regime should be
prepared to use violence to stop
revolutions this is why the people's
Liberation Army is so important to the
CCP they report directly to the party
and can quell uprisings before they gain
steam in C's mind Gorbachev allowed the
Soviet Union to fall because he didn't
have the tools to reassert power the
Communist ideology is built upon the
idea of equality that as corruption
spreads that concept breaks down and
people lose Faith as soon as C took
power he promised to go after both the
Tigers and the flies in his first public
speech
[Music]
that meant rooting out powerful but
corrupt Tigers high up in government as
well as the petulant flies engaging in
low-level bribery he didn't just lead
the charge himself though he wanted to
create a culture that had a zero
tolerance policy toward political
corruption this led to an eight-point
code to govern political Behavior no
longer would officials be allowed to
accept expensive gifts fancy cars or
even free dinners then C made a point to
publicize the trial of bosu Lai the
judge quickly ruled guilty on all counts
and handed down a lifetime sentence this
was an important message to send to any
would-be Challengers it didn't matter
how high up you were in the government
no one was immune to anti-corruption
investigations The Purge reached the
highest ranks of the Communist party
people who were normally able to operate
with impunity members of the politbura
standing committee were arrested and
charged with abuse of power high-profile
citizens were forced to turn over
billions of dollars in assets and
high-ranking military officials were
quickly stripped of their ranks every
time time C would remove someone for
corruption he would replace them with
one of his own people he understood at a
deep level from his time in government
how the system worked so no stone could
be left unturned and although his
campaign was ruthless it was hugely
popular with average Chinese citizens
there really was a ton of corruption all
throughout China and nothing could get
done without paying bribes by the time
he was done C had identified more than 4
million corrupt people throughout China
this led to a huge Improvement in
lifestyle for the average worker
peasants wouldn't need to bribe
officials anymore to get basic
assistance from the government but this
created a new problem the wealthy
Chinese Elite started to hate Xi Jinping
he had taken so much from them before
they could relax and enjoy a steady
stream of profits from their
unscrupulous business practices but now
those cash flows had dried up and no one
was safe from investigation he had to
get these people to fall in line it
wasn't enough to keep the peasants happy
and let the elites plan a response
everyone had to recognize the new
leadership the solution was to codify a
new version of the Communist Doctrine
into the party Constitution the vision
comes directly from Xi Jinping and is
referred to as socialism with Chinese
characteristics for a new era the party
now uses a mobile app to ensure that
everyone is studying the principles
important to the party the app quizzes
people on Xi Jinping thought on a daily
basis and is required for party members
University professors and young students
in order to build out this ideological
content pipeline Xi Jinping needed
support he found his answer in a Chinese
scholar named Wang huning while China
had been turning over massive swaths of
the political Elite Wong Hoon ning had
somehow managed to remain in his
position he'd served in the government
since 1995 and remained committed to the
Communist party because Xi Jinping had
such a tumultuous childhood he was never
able to develop a strong grasp of
political Theory or Western philosophy
Wang hun ning was able to fill that Gap
and develop a set of Chinese policies to
usher in a new era Wang huning had
written a book called America against
America in which he our argued that the
United States was going to tear itself
apart because citizens were granted
individual freedoms this was exactly
what Xi Jinping wanted to avoid so
rolling out a comprehensive
indoctrination campaign was the next
logical step political slogans became a
Cornerstone of this new ideology project
the Belton Road initiative the Chinese
dream common Prosperity each of these
served to solidify the new party Vision
in the minds of the populace but unlike
in America where you can choose between
Barack Obama's yes we can and Donald
Trump's make America great again in
China there was only one option
non-compliance would be met with swift
punishment the apparatus that c had
created to fight corruption could now be
used as he saw fit and it wasn't long
before he started using it to punish
Challengers even though plenty of
corrupt officials had been removed from
their positions many poor villagers were
still left empty-handed farmlands had
been sold off to the highest bidder and
local citizens had no way to reclaim
what had been stolen as protests started
to build again Xi Jinping turned his
anti-corruption campaign on the
protesters and arrested a local leader
on charges of bribery corruption was bad
but political dissent was worse absolute
control was all that mattered but
dragging people out of their homes in
the middle of the night is still a last
resort Xi Jinping realized that if he
could control the flow of information
and shape how people thought he might
never need to send in the troops again
so he set up a massive censorship
operation every message sent over the
Chinese internet would need to be
scanned first by algorithms to flag
sensitive words then by humans to review
in more detail it was exhausting work
but the Chinese government had plenty of
resources to throw at the problem they
literally employed millions of people
now just to censor internet content and
does more and more Chinese citizens gain
internet access the task has only grown
in scope the band word list is
constantly changing and has to include
lots of seemingly Bland words that could
be used to covertly Signal dissent when
the internet started really growing in
the the 1990s controlling the flow of
information seemed like an impossible
task President Bill Clinton even
described internet censorship as sort of
like trying to nail Jello to the wall
but to the Chinese Communist party it
didn't matter how difficult it was free
speech and the open internet was a
direct threat to authoritarianism lots
of independent observers had argued that
the internet had played a key role in
the Arab Spring protesters had
coordinated on social media sites and
that couldn't be allowed to happen in
China the first stress test of the
censorship apparatus came in July of
2011 when two high-speed trains crashed
40 people died and everyday citizens
turned to social media to ask questions
about how this could possibly be allowed
to happen but government sensors worked
tirelessly to shut down the conversation
120 people spent three full days
deleting posts about the accident and
the trains were quickly buried in dirt
right where the accident happened Xi
Jinping was gaining more and more
control over the internet and he wanted
to make it clear to every Party official
that censorship was a top priority a
secret memo known as document number
nine outlined how the new regime would
reject the rule of law and the West's
idea of Journalism the Crackdown
expanded to famous newspapers popular
bloggers even actors and lawyers started
to disappear from the internet anyone
who felt comfortable criticizing the
government and had a decent following
needed to be controlled the goal was to
get everyone to fall in line with the
ideological goals of the Chinese
Communist Party specifically around the
idea of national Rejuvenation this
refers to XI jinping's goal of Chinese
Supremacy everyone in the country needs
to be working to improve China directly
and that means following strict social
norms women should get married and have
babies men should be strong and stop
playing video games anything that
violates the idea of traditional Family
Values is censored and so is talking
about Xi Jinping directly a student was
actually sent to jail for six months
just for posting a picture of Winnie the
Pooh and this line is extremely blurry
there isn't a law written down somewhere
about how to speak about government
leaders you can just be punished for
saying anything C doesn't like
personally people are constantly finding
ways around specific bands but the
sensors are always just one step behind
it's a constant cat and mouse game and
it's made understanding what's really
going on in China extremely difficult
some analysts say that despite all of
this Xi Jinping is actually very popular
and that's not as crazy as it sounds
China's economy has been growing rapidly
for years now and the average living
standard of Chinese citizens is on the
rise if the alternative is chaos and
Corruption censorship might seem
acceptable to many people the Chinese
censorship machine isn't stagnating
though it's actually growing in scope
every single day over half of the
world's CCTV cameras are sold in China
those cameras are all connected to the
Chinese surveillance system citizens can
be tracked both on and offline now but
the amount of data required to do this
is overwhelming if China had human
monitors doing all of this work there
would be no one left to grow crops make
clothing or assemble iPhones so they
have to employ technology artificial
intelligence is the only way to scan
every text message image and video
uploaded to the Internet so that's where
China is investing most heavily in 2018
Xi Jinping faced a problem the
Constitution had a two-term limit on
leadership so he would have to step down
in 2022 so he changed the Constitution
to allow him to rule for Life a big
change to the structure of the
government like that would normally be
met with heated debate online but the
sensors made sure that only positive
comments survived online for more than a
few seconds the censorship was so
all-encompassing that you couldn't even
search for the term disagree support
Precision Peng was the only acceptable
opinion the censorship also extends to
areas you would think would align with
the Chinese Communist party's interest
topics like socialism trade unions and
workers movements are all banned that's
because even though the government
markets itself is communist what they
really care about is complete
authoritarian control they can't allow
smaller groups to organize and start
making demands because that could
undermine their power even though
Marxism lies at the core of Siege and
pink thought discussion of the topic is
tightly controlled ideas that seemingly
align with the goals of the Chinese
Communist Party can only be disseminated
through propaganda individuals who
spread messages of workers rights are
quickly silenced this practice was made
evident during a workers protest in
2018. no journalists were allowed to
report on what was going on
independently Xi Jinping declared that
the media must pledge absolute loyalty
to the Communist party and only print
stories directly from China State News
Agency when questioned about his
absolute control of the media C and his
fellow party members have pointed out
that American Media is politically
biased as well they argue that this is
merely the status quo but even though
Fox news May lean right and MSNBC
Maylene laughed at least America has
opposing viewpoints in China there's no
room for a difference of opinion during
that 2018 protest students started
coming out in support of the workers
after they were censored on social media
they were raided by the police in
objected to constant surveillance even
after being released these students were
assigned government jobs forced to live
in specific dormitories and even
required to wear tracking devices this
is the heart of XI jinping's China a
government that claims to serve the
peasants and workers clearly doesn't
care about individual rights or freedoms
all the talk about the plight of the
worker is merely propaganda the real
goal of the CCP is maintaining social
stability and their own power Xi Jinping
will do anything to maintain control
he's imprisoned hundreds of journalists
shut down human rights lawyers and
repressed religious groups everyone
thought it would be impossible to build
such an all-encompassing surveillance
state in the internet era but C
accomplished it by gradually ramping up
restrictions over time the watchful eye
of the Communist Party reaches every
corner of China but nowhere is it more
ever present than in the rural province
of xinjiang the uyghurs
there are mostly Muslim ethnic minority
Castle has dismissed Us fake news
thoroughly detained xinjiang is the home
of the uyghur Muslims a small minority
who speak a language that's actually
closer to Turkish than Mandarin Chinese
there are roughly 12 million uyghur
Muslims living there and for decades the
Communist party has been pushing them
harder and harder to assimilate Xi
Jinping has a metaphor that he likes to
use to describe his Grand Vision of
Chinese unification he says that all
ethnic groups should be like the seeds
of a pomegranate bound tightly together
inside one Chinese Nation sounds
reasonable in theory but this strategy
has led to brutalities I can't even
mention here on YouTube so let's focus
on the technology side of how Xi Jinping
controls the uyghurs it all starts with
propaganda historically xinjiang has
been a bit of a Battleground state it
wasn't until 1949 that the Communist
Party took power and got full control of
the territory once they did they
immediately started incentivizing Han
Chinese to move into the region to help
prevent any calls for Independence but
that's a story you won't hear on TV in
xinjiang Chinese propaganda is
constantly playing and tells a different
story one of uyghur slaves that were
liberated by the Chinese Communist party
as attention shifted from televisions to
smartphones so has the focus on the
surveillance State WeChat is the primary
communication tool throughout China and
it's also the primary method of control
it's more than just a chat app people
get their news there they pay for things
with the app they can even trade stocks
but the CCP has full visibility into
what goes on inside the app and they use
that information to Target anyone that
they think might be interested in
undermining the current regime or even
just promoting the uyghur culture as a
unique identity in one particularly
horrific case the party targeted a
linguist who had returned to xinjiang
after studying abroad to teach the
uyghur language to locals they tossed
him in an unmarked car through a black
bag over his head and took him to a
Detention Facility he had been accused
of being a CIA spy sent by America to
encourage Revolution they also claimed
that he had misreported financials of a
related company really anything to cover
up the truth he was being silenced just
for continuing to spread the uyghur
language and culture he was humiliated
and tortured before getting sentenced to
years in prison for his alleged crimes
and since then more than a million
uyghurs have been sent through these
detention centers it wasn't always this
way before c came to power the uyghurs
thought he might actually usher in a new
era of Peace after all his father had
been particularly soft on China's ethnic
minority groups but C had a different
plan social stability at any cost these
brutal strategies have a hidden cost
though the goal of all this oppression
is to reduce the amount of unrest in
xinjiang but the primary cause of unrest
in xinjiang is all the oppression the
end result is an extremely unstable
cycle of violence and human rights
abuses Xi Jinping would argue that his
actions are limited in scope and
ultimately outweighed by the benefits of
social stability after all economic
growth has been high in xinjiang so in
his mind the policies are working
even though the oppression in xinjiang
has its roots in religious and cultural
conflict economic factors are becoming
more and more important globalization
has led to many American companies
having close ties to China Apple needs
China to make iPhones big Financial
firms need Chinese investors and even
the NBA needs China to help expand their
viewership it's led to a situation where
a huge swath of Americans can't speak
openly about China without fear of
consequences this kind of international
influences unprecedented in history and
it's becoming a massive source of
strength for Xi Jinping American
celebrities are afraid of criticizing
him they know it will hurt their
professional prospects so they stay
silent the sheer scale of XI jinping's
influence is hard to wrap your head
around it's really not an exaggeration
to call him the most powerful man in the
world after all he has absolute control
over the Chinese Communist party which
has nearly 100 million members and the
CCP has absolute control over China's
entire population of 1.4 billion people
there are no checks and balances in
China C doesn't have to get approval
from Senators to make new laws and his
decisions can't be challenged by
independent courts remember when Nancy
Pelosi caused a big stir by visiting
Taiwan the trip was viewed by the
International Community as a sign that
America would support Taiwan in a future
conflict and Xi Jinping didn't like the
sound of that he actually called Joe
Biden directly and warned that the visit
would escalate tensions think about that
for a second Xi Jinping basically called
the president of the United States and
told him to stop the speaker of the
house from visiting Taiwan it's an
outrageous demand but perhaps most
importantly it reflects a fundamental
misunderstanding of how the American
government works Nancy Pelosi doesn't
work for Joe Biden the legislative and
executive branches of the U.S government
are separate entities Biden really can't
tell Representatives what to do he just
doesn't have the authority but Xi
Jinping does have that kind of absolute
Authority he answers to no one and has
no limits on his power but why is Taiwan
so important to Xi Jinping it it's a
complicated question but one worth
understanding because it drives so much
of his thinking the history of Taiwan
has always been tumultuous the island
nation has an indigenous population that
has lived there for thousands of years
but they haven't lived in isolation for
centuries Han Chinese started arriving
in the 13th century with Dutch
Portuguese and Spanish explorers
arriving in the 17th century in 1895
Japan took control of the island after
the first sino-japanese war and held
onto it for 50 years but in 1949
millions of Chinese fled the mainland
after the Communist Party took control
they lived in Exile and slowly developed
Taiwan into the Democratic and
self-governing Country we see today Xi
Jinping argues that Taiwan is rightfully
part of China and needs to be reunited
with the mainland but his claims are
fairly arbitrary Taiwan was independent
then it wasn't and now it's independent
again arguing that we have to go back to
how things were in the 1800s and strip
Taiwan of its independence has no
logical basis you could just as easily
say we need to go back to the year 1200
and leave Taiwan independent Xi Jinping
is not a rational actor though he's
acting ideologically he needs to focus
on making the world safe for
dictatorships and taiwan's independent
democracy is a major threat
fundamentally Xi Jinping believes in
Marxist leninism at a very deep level
his mother taught at the leading Marxist
Academy and his educational career was
focused on the subject one of the key
ideas in Marxism is controlling the
means of production Industrial policy is
a huge part of that Xi Jinping can't
create a flourishing Marxist China if
they have no control over the production
of Advanced Technologies so that's the
real reason why Taiwan is so important
the real question is why hasn't C
already invaded Taiwan he has the power
he needs to launch an invasion and the
military has been planning and preparing
for years well Taiwan is not an easy
target even though it's much smaller
than mainland China conditions in the
Taiwan Strait are treacherous the
beaches are heavily fortified and the
Taiwanese military has built up ground
defenses for years Joe Biden has also
continually made statements that America
will defend Taiwan from unprovoked
invasions so for now C is biding his
time building up his military and
waiting until there is an opportune
moment but he's also had other problems
to deal with for the last two years
kovid has presented new challenges and
unexpectedly new opportunities for Xi
Jinping when the virus first broke out
in Wuhan C tried to sweep it under the
rug his internet sensors blocked any
mention of the virus and even doctors
with first-hand experience were silenced
this policy backfired though and it
quickly became clear that the virus was
going to spread across the globe so C
pivoted from a strategy of ignoring the
threat of kovid to one of Maximum fear
he locked down entire cities restricted
travel and ramped up the surveillance
State fear of the virus was enough of an
excuse to start tracking every single
Citizen's physical location at all times
it was an entirely new level of control
but it was working C had been built his
surveillance system slowly over time but
covid provided a breakthrough now anyone
could be tracked ostensibly to reduce
covet infections but it's impossible to
ignore how this further empowers the
police state as Draconian as the zero
coveted policy was it did work at least
for a few years the lockdowns prevented
the virus from spreading but
unemployment was on the rise and the
economic toll began to climb during the
Shanghai lockdowns the local economy
shrunk 14 and more and more young people
were out of work it's important to
understand what Xi Jinping was thinking
around this time it was clear that
lockdowns hurt economic growth but this
actually wasn't that big of a problem
China had been growing rapidly for
decades and so the population was quite
happy with how things were going
generally yes obviously these lockdowns
were a setback but average citizens were
still looking at the general upward
Trend and willing to sacrifice for the
greater good there were other factors to
consider as well compared to the West
China doesn't have the same level of
Hospital infrastructure they never
approved mRNA vaccines and they never
developed a base level of natural
immunity Xi Jinping had plenty of good
reasons to enforce lockdowns but those
might have just been covered to allow
him to further consolidate power after
all in October of 2022 China held the
20th National Party Congress all eyes
were on Xi Jinping who should have
stepped down if he was following the
typical succession plan that Chinese
leaders had been adhering to for the
past few decades but that's not what
happened C had successfully dispatched
every political opponent cemented his
hold on the Communist party and
guaranteed that he could rule
indefinitely it wasn't entirely
unexpected but many Chinese citizens
took issue with this aggressive decision
exact statistics about XI jinping's
popularity are hard to come by for
obvious reasons in the wake of C's third
term announcement even the letter N was
banned on social media this is because
people were simply posting n equals 3 or
n equals infinity to comment on the
number of terms he might serve even
though I've tried to cover as much as
possible about Xi Jinping there are
still tons of gaps in this story his
whole life is shrouded in secrecy and
unbiased reporting is very hard to come
by that's why it's so important to
support the sources who made all this
possible I'll leave links to additional
information down below the story is
still evolving too China and the United
States have been on a collision course
for years and a battle for the control
of the semiconductor industry is heating
up if you want to understand how Xi
Jinping is thinking about China's
artificial intelligence strategy just
watch this video next thanks for
watching